Liraz Margalit, thank you so much
for joining me on my show.
How are you?
I'm very well. Thank you.
Fantastic.
I'm especially good now
because I'm very excited for this talk.
Because I'm going to learn
over these next 20 minutes
as much as I can
about behavioral economics.
Especially in building products
for customers in the digital age.
I have a true passion
for behavioral economics.
I got to spend some few months
very close with Dan Ariely
at Irrational Labs.
So, I'm excited to learn
about your experiences and your teaching.
You're also a university lecturer
at the IDC for many years.
And you're a strategic advisor
to many companies.
So, Liraz, give me the overview.
Who are you?
And why behavioral economics?
Okay. Great.
So, as you mentioned,
my name is Liraz Margalit.
I have PhD in psychology.
I'm specialized
in decision making processes,
cognition, behavioral economics.
And over the past few years,
I've been utilizing models
from cognitive psychology,
behavioral economics,
and neural psychology
to better understand how customers behave
in the digital world.
And what I truly passionate about
is the differences between
the online world and the offline world.
And I think that sometimes
we are not aware,
but we behave completely different
online and offline.
Right?
Yeah. And I'm really excited to learn
the influences of the technology
on our behavior,
our emotions and our feelings.
So, let's start from the basics.
Let's start from the foundation,
behavioral economics.
What is the study of behavioral economics?
Okay. So, actually today
we are talking about behavioral design.
But let's start with behavioral economics.
And we started off with an assumption.
Actually, it's a very logical assumption.
And the assumption is that
we are rational human being.
That we have rational decision
and moreover, that we are in control
of our decisions offline and online.
And the thing is that
we have a defense mechanism.
Meaning that, we really like to think
that our decisions, our behavior
are rational.
And the thing is that we are not begin
to imagine the effect of cognitive biases,
of environmental cues, of our emotions
on the way we make decisions.
And, you know what, Michael?
When we are talking
about the online arena,
this problem is getting much bigger.
Wait, Liraz, before we get to the online.
Give me some examples.
What happens in my day to day life,
whether it's when I go buy wine
at the store,
or when I choose a subscription
for The Economist paper or digital,
give me some examples
of where do I see irrationality?
And I'm telling you,
I am the most irrational person
you'll ever meet.
You can ask my girlfriend.
She'll testify for this.
But I want you to convince
everybody else listening
that we are all irrational.
So, let me give you two example.
Two quick example.
So, I work with a company named Allianz.
It is an insurance company.
Yes.
And you know that they have their policy.
And they wanted to ask people,
they usually, on a regular basis,
ask people declaration of their health.
And one of these question is,
do you smoke.
And the thing is that most people,
interestingly, say that,
they are not smoking.
And of course, they're lying.
So, we wanted to understand
how we can make sure
that people are saying the truth.
Because it caused a lot of money
to the company.
So, I suggested
to frame the question differently.
So, instead of asking people,
do you smoke,
I suggested asking,
when was the last time you smoke.
Right.
What is the difference?
Why are those two questions
ridiculously different?
So, the thing is that if I ask you,
when's the last time you smoke,
that means that I acknowledge the fact
that you smoke.
And that's fine and that's okay.
And now you belong to a group of smokers.
So, that makes it okay.
And now, if I know that,
and if I make you realize
that I know you're smoking,
it's very hard lying about it.
So, that's the whole thing.
That's the whole idea
of behavioral economics.
It's about framing things differently.
So, we have the famous question of
[--]
So, let's say that you decided
to go to a movie.
And now, you decided
to buy the ticket, let's say online.
And you come to the movie,
you come to the theater.
And then you realize
that you lost your ticket.
What are you going to do.
Now, bear with me.
I'm going to ask this question
differently.
The same question, but differently.
Okay. So, let's say that you decided
to see a movie.
And this time you decided
that you are not going to buy
the ticket online.
So, you decided to go to the theater
and buy the tickets there.
So, you arrived to the theater
and then you opened your wallet.
You open up your wallet and you found out
that you are missing
a 50 dollar, or 20 dollar.
And then you ask yourself,
"Okay. What am I going to do now?"
"Am I going to buy another ticket?"
So, guess what?
In the first scenario, people usually,
they are not going to buy another ticket.
But in the second scenario,
they are going to buy another ticket.
And why is that?
So, why don't they. Yeah.
Because in the first scenario,
they feel like they spent,
like if ticket cost $20,
they feel like they spent $40
on one ticket.
But interestingly, in the second scenario
they don't correlate the money.
They don't group them together.
Exactly. In mentally.
Meaning, so, they don't associate
the money that lost
and the ticket to the theater
and then it's fine to buy another ticket.
But if we think about it,
this is not a rational behavior.
Because we are talking about
the same amount of money.
Yeah, exactly.
And so, Liraz, just like these examples,
there are hundreds more out there
that from every part of our lives.
One of the first examples
that I was introduced to
was this notion of buying a wine bottle
at the supermarket
and how we often tend to go and buy
the median price for a bottle of wine.
And if they add
an additional bottle of wine at the end
that is more expensive,
then we opt up to go buy there.
Right.
Think I might have lost you.
No. I'm here.
Right. So, I was giving my own example
of going to the wine store
and understanding that human behavior
tends to go to purchase
the median dollar amount
for a bottle of wine.
But then, if marketers are smart about it
and realize this,
they can just add
an extra expensive bottle of wine
at the end, and all of a sudden,
most customers shift
to the little bit more expensive option.
But Liraz, I want us now
stir a little bit away from these
general behavioral economics examples
and talk a little bit more broadly
about your work in the digital age.
So, a lot of these are tangible,
physical examples in our daily lives.
But what is different as we progress
into the 21st century in terms of
behavioral economics in online?
So, the actual difference
is how we can use it
in a practical manner.
And let me give you an example
that concern our everyday lives.
And we're talking about the same example.
So now in your example and in my example,
we actually talked about
the ethical framing.
How we frame our decision.
So, let's just continue
with what you are just about to say.
Okay. Great.
So, the differences
when we're talking about our environment,
the technology environment, is that
we are talking about the same effect
of behavioral economics
but in a practical manner.
And today, we know that
so many tech companies
actually adopted those principles
of behavioral economics.
But I have to say that sometimes
it's not in a very ethical way.
Let me give you two examples.
Please.
So, the first example is that
to use the same principle
that we were discussing right now,
and this principle is called framing,
or relative thinking, or anchoring,
you can name it different ways.
But the idea is that
the way we frame the decision,
the way we frame the digital environment,
actually is going to change our behavior.
And the thing is that,
in the digital, it's very very easy
to change the digital environment.
And let's say that you get up
in the morning,
and you know that most people today,
when they get up in the morning,
the first thing that they are going to do
is to check upt their smartphone
To check up if they have new notification.
And let me tell you something,
sometimes they do it
even in the middle of the night.
So that, even maybe
they have such an important notification
that they have to take.
So now, let me give you an imagine.
And what I'm talking about now,
I like to call it
the power of the default.
What is the default?
The default is that
you open up your smartphone
and you see all those notification.
But imagine this.
Imagine that you get up in the morning
and you see your smartphone,
your nice smartphone said,
"Good morning, Michael."
"Have a nice day."
And maybe he's going to give you
a flower or something.
So, these are two different ways
where we can frame
your good morning environment.
The reason that we choose to give you
those notification,
it's actually a message.
And these messages look all you missed
when you were sleeping.
And that means don't sleep.
If you're going to sleep,
you are going to miss so many things.
So, don't sleep.
And of course, we don't consider this.
Why?
Because we are so used to it.
Because behavioral design is embedded
in a transparent way in our everyday life.
So, we didn't even give it the thought
that things could be different, right?
Or let's say, I would say,
the big influencer of behavioral economics
or manipulator, booking.com.
So, booking.com has this way of,
let's say that
you are looking up for a hotel.
And one room left.
Exactly.
One room left and actually,
[--]
So, let's say, so many people
are looking at this specific room
when you are looking at this room.
So, these are two examples
how we can manipulate people's feelings,
people's decision,
And we didn't even start
on those special days.
Like selling days.
Like we have cyber mondays,
Or like fridays, when everything you buy
is supposed to be on sale.
And people buy things
that they don't need.
And [--]
And more than 40% of items
that are bought in those selling days
are being thrown away after this.
But we think that we actually won.
That we actually have a good deal.
That's because they are manipulated
to think that.
So, all of that is incredibly fascinating.
And all these examples
of behavioral economics.
But you're strategic adviser
to quite a few companies.
And what I'm extremely curious about
is how practically do you go and
and do you incorporate
this academic research
of behavioral economics
into everyday startups?
Because when I look at myself
as a young entrepreneur,
I'm going to create my own startup.
Now, I'm very passionate
about behavioral economics.
So, maybe, I'll have a little bit
more experience and knowledge
than the average person
starting a company.
But what are the ways
in which you come
and help these companies,
like you mentioned, with Allianz?
And what can founders and entrepreneurs do
to become better engaged
with this content?
Okay. Great question.
So, what I like to do with startups
is habit forming.
And by habit forming, we mean
how to take a product
and form a habit out of it.
Because the thing about habits
is really interesting.
Because when there is an initiate behavior
and when there is the habit,
we are talking about
two different brain areas.
Because habit is unconscious.
And that means
that you don't need to think
about what you are doing.
So, let's say you are going on Facebook.
Sometimes we don't even consider this.
This is not where
we're talking about rationality.
So, when we are talking about habit,
this is not irrational action.
And this is why we are eager
to turn every behavior,
every actually a set of behaviors
into a habit.
So, let's say that you have a new app.
Why are habit so strong, by the way?
Why are habits so strong?
Okay. So, the thing is that,
our brain will try to take every action
and turn it into a habit.
Because habit does not require
cognitive resources,
mental resources from our brain.
So, when we lock out our door,
when we brush our teeth in the morning,
we don't think about it.
And if you think about it,
you can lock your door
and then you can think about,
like your presentation
that you need to present today
to your boss.
And you could think about
who is going to pick up the kids
from the kindergarten.
So, your brain is free
to think about other tasks.
And that is why habits are so important.
The thing is that,
when companies come to me,
they think that
they can turn every behavior
into a habit.
And that is not correct.
Because there are behaviors
that you cannot turn into a habit.
And when we're talking about habits,
we have the habit look.
Meaning that we need to have a trigger
to the behavior.
We need to have the routine
and we need to have the reward.
And your reward is extremely important
because if the reward is powerful,
then we will remember it.
And then we want to actually repeat
the behavior again.
And it will repeat the behavior
several times.
And it's not 21 days
like people like to say.
It depends on the actual behavior.
Then your product will become
a part of the customer's routine.
And this is the holy grail.
So, when you join a startup as an adviser,
do you come in just one time?
You just say,
"Oh, okay, you're trying to do XYZ."
"Here is the habit."
"Here is how you do it."
Or is it a more thorough process
along the way?
No, because we have many habits.
Every click is a habit.
So, we need to think about
the specific rewards.
But there is another thing
that we need to do these days.
And we are talking about personalization.
And now we are in the world
of personalization.
And the thing about personalization
that for so many years,
we are trying to reach that point,
that level.
But I think I really believe that
on the last two years
we were able to have some progress
in personalization.
And by personalization,
I mean that when you walk,
or when you land on a website or app,
you will have a different experience
compared to me.
And that means that
we need to get to know our user.
And that doesn't mean demographic.
I'm not talking about demographics at all.
I'm talking about personality.
And I'm talking about
decision making style.
So, today I can take your
Facebook profile, for example,
and I can know who you are
only based on your Facebook,
your Twitter, your LinkedIn.
So, actually, I don't need
so much information from you.
And even if you think about
the actual behavior, the actual traces
that we live in the online world,
we can learn so much from those traces.
So, let's say that you fill in a form.
So, I can tell using behavioral analytics,
I can tell how you type.
How fast, how slow you type.
So, if you are lying,
I know that you will type slower,
for example.
And I know if you decided
to skip on a field
and then come back to it.
And that means that I want to see
what you are doing
and why you actually behave this way.
And sometimes,
I actually plant manipulation.
And let's say that there is a button
or a click that doesn't work.
I like to see how people
actually click on this button.
Meaning that are they eagerly click
one after time or are they passionate.
And that means a lot about their behavior.
About who they are.
Wow. Liraz, this is fascinating,
I can ask you 100 more questions
about this, but unfortunately,
I called my show 20 minute leader,
so, I have to uphold to that.
But I want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
It's been such a pleasure and an honor.
And I'd love to continue learning more
from your work.
And hopefully talk to you
when I have my own startup.
But before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. Great.
I think that the three words
that mostly describe me is
it's all about passion. Passionate.
Passionate. It's all about passion.
Culminating in passionate.
I think that definitely exudes
through this conversation.
Liraz, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This is so wonderful.
And I look forward to chatting again.
Great.
Take care.
Than you for inviting me. Bye bye.
Okay. Liraz, before we leave,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Great. So, the three words are
it's all about passion.
It's all about passion.
Again, it completely exudes
through the screen.
I love the wok that you're doing.
I love behavioral economics.
And I think it's just so fascinating
to think about the rationality
and irrationality
of human decision making.
And the fact that you're taking this
into a deep dive into the digital world
and thinking critically
about how we do things.
I think it's remarkable.
So, thank you very very much.
And I look forward to remaining in touch.
Thank you so much for inviting me.
Bye bye.